look who's here
i never knew there was a school in the
building
i got a note one day to show up and i
loved it from the moment we began
i like going to school inside of a
nursing
home because it's learning a lot of
stuff from elderly
going to school here is like going to
school with my grandparents
it's awesome it's very awesome
[Music]
my name is zelda fassler i'm a resident
of the hebrew home i've been working
with the hope
class since
just about two months after i got here
what kind of feelings do you guys get
from this painting over here can you
guys see it the whole program is very
unique because it's a high school within
a nursing home facility
you guys can just charge the second page
the hope program is a vocational program
that started back in the 90s that gives
students with intellectual disabilities
the opportunity to split their time
between being in their different
departments their academic studies
[Music]
and then working with the residents and
interact with them on a daily basis i
think it's a win-win for both the
residents and the students they share
ideas past experiences and gain
different perspectives on how life is
today
i feel that most of them
are like grandchildren to me i see them
around the home we stop we talk some of
them knock on my door
one day she'll just come in for a hug
the twins come in for a hug
it's a lovely feeling feelings
zelda is one of my favorite residents
she's very sweet she's very kind and she
welcomes me with a smile she was like a
grandparent to me and i get to see her
every day and i enjoy that
the thrifty social worker
zelda comes to class
and we read together we read like in the
group
i learned so many things from her i'm
lucky to have them and the longer we're
together the closer we get and the more
they look to me
as a grandparent i think they think of
me in that day not just because i never
act like a teacher i'm there to help
them
to explain things to them to be his
executive oh it's not executed
it's what keeps me my mind fresh it's
what keeps me feeling young people say
you move into a nursing home
and that's it
but the hope
class gives my life here
meaning
[Music]
you